good morning everyone
and welcome to the fcga
annual webinar this year themed the
future of work
my name is juanita clark and i'm the
chief executive officer
of the digital council africa i'm
broadcasting this morning
from a very very cold pretoria south
africa
today it is my privilege to lead
the fiber council global alliance annual
2021 project for those who do not know
who the fiber council global alliance is
the fcga consists of the five councils
co-representing the fiber industry in
the regions across the world
in 2012 the five councils came together
in munich
germany and signed an mou to outline
this memorandum of understanding and our
collaboration
the fcga comprises of regions across the
world
including europe the americas which
includes
north america as well as latin america
the middle east
and north africa or mena as well as asia
pacific
the council signed this mou to
strengthen our collaboration
and to drive the message of the great
need for high-speed broadband
connectivity
across the globe we felt at the time
that it was appropriate
that we agreed on the message that we
wanted to send
across the globe and i hope to some
extent
with succeeded the fcga
meets regularly to collaborate on
general topics of
interest within the fiber community and
of course one such initiative which most
of you will know about
is the global definition of terms
since i joined the fcj almost a decade
ago
many faces have changed and as a result
i've been privileged to work with some
of the greatest minds
in the global sector people that have
truly
understood the industry the importance
of this technology
people that have in-depth knowledge of
the challenges that
that face their respective regions
and people that have a clear
understanding of the policy and
regulatory environments
and the requirements that shape our
regions
i've been privileged to spend time in
brussels with the european commission
who extensively presented their
broadband strategy and their vision for
europe
and i've had the privilege to meet with
fcc in washington
who shared their challenges of broadband
in rural america
the leaders in their respective regions
have immense convening power
and influence and i'm sure that today
every person on this webinar will walk
away having learned
something today
the global leadership of the fcga will
themselves
prevent the present the findings of
the 2021 webinar
as mentioned before the fcga strive to
develop
an annual research paper which often
culminates
into a webinar in early 2021
we thought it appropriate to consider
the pandemic as everybody was across the
globe
but for us it was important to look at
the impact on the telecommunications
sector
more specifically on the broadband
sector
we wanted to better understand what
impact access to broadband had on the
workforce
amongst other things we wanted to
understand the challenges that people
who do not have access
were facing this research
that is conducted annually and was
conducted globally
and mainly between the first and the
second wave of the pandemic
before i hand over to our keynote
speakers
allow me to just quickly do a little bit
of housekeeping
this morning as we present our findings
of this research paper
you're going to be asked to participate
in two polls as mentioned before
our research was conducted between the
first and the second wave
but speaking for myself just in south
africa
we're already in the third wave and
currently in a
hard lockdown in south africa so when
you receive these polls what we're
trying to do
is to see if anything has changed in the
last couple of months
since we've done our research so that we
can then have a discussion about
that towards the end of our webinar
as mentioned there will be a short round
table discussion at the end of the
presentation
led by the leadership of the fcga
representing their respective regions
and maybe drilling down a little bit
more
into the findings of their specific that
was things that were specific to their
regions
so please feel free to post your
questions and your comments
in the question box and we will then
present them to the speakers towards the
end
then lastly please allow me to introduce
you
please introduce yourself in the chat if
you so wish of course it's not
compulsory but if you'd like to please
introduce yourself in the chat
it's always nice to know who has joined
us and where you based in the world
so please feel free to to share who you
are and where you're from in the chat
and then
of course now with further ado
allow me to introduce you to mr vincent
garnier
our keynote speaker and vincent
is the the director general of
the fcg of the
um european chapter
joining vincent is this morning
is gary bolton who's the
president and ceo of
the americas and he will represent
both north america as well as the latin
chapter
then also welcome to rusafi alam
who is the general manager for the asia
pacific region
and also joining us this morning is
khaloot aldorgam
who is the director general for
the middle east and north africa as
mentioned my name is juanita clark
it's a great privilege to be with you
today and
on that note um it's a great pleasure to
hand over
to vincent garnier of
ftch council europe vincent over to you
well thank you very much juanita i'll
move to the next slide and
welcome good morning good afternoon
everybody i will start with some
information
and i need to first move the slide in
the right direction
yeah i will start with some information
regarding the methodology
used for this study the survey
has been conducted as one it has said at
the end
of april early may for a period of
two weeks regional council
invited its respective audiences to
participate
each of us use the very same
questionnaire
but it has been distributed by each
council
independently we contacted our members
as well as a variety of professionals
active in the telecom ecosystem
from our contact list we received
answers from people from
a large variety of roles starting from
c-level architects engineers but also
marketing professionals
consultants and investors
in total the survey we are presenting
the result of today
is based upon almost 500 responses
at global level
now if you if we analyze a bit more in
detail
the profile of respondents
we see that the different types of
organization
active in our industry are well
represented
network operators and vendors make
two-thirds
of the respondent and contractors nearly
10
the breakdown by geographies by region
shows a certain
over-representation of north america and
to a lesser extent
latin america this probably represents
the the importance and the size
of the north american association
compared to
to the other region um and
it could maybe limit a little bit the
relevance of some comparison between
region
although one of the key takeaway of this
survey
is the remarkable homogeneity of answers
on the most important questions so
actually we do not think that the
geographical distribution
is too much an issue having said that we
are conscious that
the sample surveyed is not precisely
representative of the actual population
we are focusing on the telecom industry
and as i said some regions are a bit
less represented than
others it should therefore be seen
as a contribution to the very important
subject
of the future of work and will
complement
and strengthen similar studies made
on the same theme so
before i dive into the details of the of
the results
uh i would like to share with you some
key
takeaways the first
concerns work from home policies
company policies a clear consequence of
the pandemic
is that companies have been forced to
formalize
work from home policies for their
employees
over 50 percent of the respondents
declare
that their company had no work policy
work from home policy prior to the
covet-19 crisis
but they are close to 80 percent to
declare
that they now have won a very big shift
working from home is no longer seen as a
privilege
authorized for the happy few but it has
become
now a standard practice accessible to
most employees and which has proven its
value during the pandemic
this result is actually consistent with
the answer
to another question we we asked to our
panel
which indicates that 75 percent of the
respondent
expect to be working from home at least
on a part basis partial basis rotational
basis
by the end of the year
the second key finding i would like to
share with you is that
residential internet is no longer seen
as a luxury
prior to long done and orders to stay
the inefficiencies of internet service
were
tolerated as the hybrid household
used internet services largely for
entertainment
and email rather than the entire
household simultaneously using
bandwidth hungry application for mission
critical work
or education or connecting with friends
and family
so the utilization of the internet
shifted from
simply being a tool for entertainment
purpose
to more critical applications such as
attending important
professional meetings via collaboration
tools
and children having to participate in
classrooms to ensure
that they stay up to date with their
curriculum
when asked about the challenges of
working from home 52 percent
of respondents indicate that bandwidth
either download or upload and internet
connectivity
were among the top challenges
these results concur with the feedback
we hear from most operators in our
different regions
the pandemic has significantly changed
the way
subscribers internet subscribers see
residential internet
it becomes a must and people are
more likely to pay attention to the
performance of their broadband service
even though we will see later that they
still struggle to understand
technology differences between the
different broadband technologies
we and that's the third finding we we
also asked the question whether the
pandemic had encouraged people to
relocate
our survey indicates that 83 percent
of respondents have not relocated yet
now this does not mean that the pandemic
will not have a longer term impact on
where people decide to leave
there are multiple signs showing that
people are looking for
larger homes looking for adding one or
two rooms to be more comfortable
for working from home
they are also considering moving to new
areas all together
and are looking to towns with a good
connectivity
these towns now actually are called zoom
towns
for example some families in the united
states
are moving away from big cities like
chicago
in favor of less expensive areas such as
florida beaches
while other opted for more rural or
mountainous
areas such as texas and montana
it is in these areas where affordability
less crowding and stress levels and
improved work
life balance were cited as reason for
the move
in south africa this is being referred
as
sea migration maybe juanita you will be
able to tell us more about this
later during the q a session
and according to the u.s national
association of
realtors one in three workers is
considering
moving to a new state if remote working
continues now these trends
have not been measured yet in our survey
as they take time to materialize but
they are nevertheless
uh very much pregnant in in our in our
societies today
and finally we wanted to highlight that
we got several feedback around the idea
of
feeling safe at home
interestingly some respondent indicated
that feeling safe
from a health perspective and the
ability
to work internationally without
traveling
were particularly beneficial to them it
was not
a specific question we asked it came
spontaneously
expressed via the comments section of
the survey
for some clearly the lockdown has not
been seen
as a constraint but more as an
opportunity
to enjoy the protection of their home
while staying
connected to the world so maybe a
different perspective from
what is perceived by the majority but it
was interesting to to highlight this
point
so after highlighting these four key
findings
let us move to the next line which
analyzes
the various access network technologies
we asked our audience the type of
broadband internet technology
they were using at home the gripe on
this slide
partly is partly consistent with what we
know of the situation of each region
for instance cable or hfc networks
are well represented in north america
and latin america
whereas it's a bit less present in
europe and apac and quasi non-existent
in middle east and africa satellite only
appears in north america and africa
which
makes sense according to to our parallel
information
however respondents are
seem to be under-representing
the traditional corporate telecom line
and also we notice
that wireless seems to have been
confused with wi-fi
despite the fact that our audience is
supposed to be
particularly well informed about
broadband technology
these results are a good illustration
that when people are asked to react as
simple broadband consumers subscribers
that do not really care about the access
network technology they are using
additional elements in the survey like
qualitative comments
clearly indicated that subscribers have
a very simple approach when it comes to
their internet connection
it works it doesn't it is fast
it is slow period when we discuss with
operators
many share similar findings about
subscribers approach
of their internet connection
technically most access network
technologies
end up with a wi-fi router which is the
interface
subscribers are familiar with so
actually they don't really want to know
about the technology behind
that's at least a striking finding of
this
of this survey
now when we are trying to
ask our audience to identify
the key technology challenge they had
while working from home we see that
half of the problems are related to
connectivity
lack of bandwidth internet connectivity
failures or vpn crashing
and we saw some significant differences
there between region latin american
respondent indicated bandwidth
constraints being
highest at 41 followed by north america
at 33 percent
while europe was much lower
um to highlight this these problems with
22 percent
and sub-sahara africa only 12
this could be correlated with the fact
that cable broadband
is reported as insufficient cable
compared to fiber connection
people beings in higher proportion in
the u.s compared to
to europe for instance many respondents
indicated that current speed on their
cable supplied internet
was insufficient especially in terms of
upload speed
which has become critical for video
calls and many applications
using the internet connection from home
several respondents indicated that their
connectivity challenges
were not resolved and ultimately had
to waiting out along with the usual
basic
self-sustain troubleshooting techniques
such as rebooting routers
modems and pcs some relief came
about by simply going to the office when
it was safe to do so
upgrading the internet service to
support higher speed
when it was available seville's
call to provider and working with remote
i.t
department but for others
more extreme what is called here brute
force
uh tactics such as switching off cameras
is almost in almost all video
conferencing systems
rearranging video conferencing time to
non-busy hours
and switching to single room office
space at business centers
were among the remedies
it is commonly understood that fixed
network in most region
really passed the test of the pandemic
during the first
wave and that the vast majority of the
population has been able to work
or learn remotely during the lockdown
periods
what our survey shows is that this has
been achieved
with some time really sub-optimal
experience and some poor connectivity
situations
which have maybe been perceived as
acceptable
during these unexpected and exceptional
circumstances will certainly not be
tolerated
when remote working becomes a recurring
practice
the brutal shift to work from home has
put a lot of stress on
companies digital infrastructure
our survey has tried to measure what
type of i.t investments
have been made as a direct consequence
of the generalization
of remote working in attempts to improve
the work from home experience
and keep productivity business
took action with respect to updating
infrastructure
and capacity these efforts and
investment
include purchasing more servers and
software
for more vpn to increase capacity
moving software to cloud environments
supporting employees with remote working
software and hardware
and that includes collaboration
applications
the investment also concern i.t service
and data security
adding extra space to file sharing into
cloud connectivity and digital
signatures
it is in these areas where some relief
can be achieved
however they will not solely help at
home workers being able to conduct
high volume internet related activities
if they do not have enough bandwidth
or a high enough speed
for the internet service to support the
the expected usage
so the slide highlights some regional
differences
like the higher investment level in mina
the important data security investment
in africa compared to
north america for example or the
importance of in-home network security
software investment
in latin america
while employees have been stuck at home
and were facing some connectivity issue
we wanted to measure what technical
support they received from their
companies
it was it's worth nothing that it's
worth
noting sorry that why some companies
were well prepared to support remote
workforce
many found themselves in the position of
having to make changes in technology
investment
both infrastructure subsidies and
devices
this investment came in several ways to
alleviate
issues or improve the at-home work
experience
and support work-at-home employees
including
laptop purchases for every employee
subsidizing
commonly used technology such as
internet and phone services
company that did not already support
remote workforces
handled support in a few ways but this
varied region
to region so according to to the
feedback we got from the respondent of
our survey
regions with the lowest equipment
subsidies were
latin america mina middle east and north
africa
and asia pacific while europe and
sub-saharan
africa have reported higher level of
equipment subsidies
on the other hand a small percentage of
respondents indicated that their company
made no investment at all
to support the shift to remote work
meaning employees purchase their own
laptop camera desk monitors
while some were allowed to take
equipment from the office
and bring them back home
in our next slide we will show the
proportion
of professional which think that they
will return
to the office by the end of the year
either
full-time or part-time but before i
share the result with you
let me ask you the very same question
thanks to the poll function available on
our webinar platform
so it should appear on your screen now
the question is will you return
personally to the office
by the end of 2021 and will you do that
100 will you do it on a rotational basis
and will it do it at 50 capacity or
do you plan to stay working from home
so i give you maybe another 20 seconds
i'm i'm looking at the the collection
of uh results now it's progressing
nicely
i think we now have uh 60 of the
audience
um having voted let's give you another
20 seconds to to express your view on
this question
and then we will we will share the
result
i think i can now
we seem to stabilize at 70 percent of
attendee
voting maybe another few seconds
all right
so
17 of you uh declare that they will
return permanently
in the office at the end of the year
approximately half uh or 60
of the respondents say that it will be
on a retentional basis or 50
capacity and 26 percent
plan to stay working remotely
and this is quite interesting because it
seems to be very consistent
with what i will share with you right
now
moving to the next slide
yeah so let's look at the answer from
our survey to
the very same question only
23 percent plan to return full time to
the office
at the end of 2021 and you indicated
17 we are very at a very similar level
30 say they will remain in remote
workforce mode while
our audience say 26 percent it's it's
very striking how close the results are
and about half of the respondents say
they will adopt a hybrid approach
going to the office on a rotational
basis or
at 50 staff capacity
actually our findings are fully aligned
with the gartner survey
from the end of 2020 which revealed that
82 percent
of company leaders said they plan to
allow employees to remote work
to remote to work remotely at least
some of the time and many reports in
different regions concur with this
this is also consistent with the
information we shared earlier about the
strong development
of work from home company policies
many of which are acting the fact that
employee can
work remotely at least part-time
however we should point out that our
survey concerns mainly professional
which can
work which work can be performed
remotely
and i guess the same goes for for the
audience of the webinar today
it's not representative of the entire
population and it's clear that
for many roles in manufacturing retail
or
for instance working from home is simply
not an option
nevertheless the results confirm that
the crisis we are going through
is very likely to have a
significant long-term impact on the way
we work
for a large global organization this is
probably just an acceleration
of an evolution which started before
2020
but for many small mid-sized businesses
especially the more traditional one this
is a major change with has which has to
be
operated in a very short period of time
before the coronavirus crisis many
managers were reluctant to develop
remote working because they assume it
would
probably negatively impact the
productivity of their team
so in our survey we address this point
and before i share the result let me
bring
our second poll and ask the very same
question to you
so this concerns productivity and
do you think that productivity increased
decreased or stayed the same
during the pandemic
again i let you click
on the on the different possible answers
um
already 50 of you have already voted
let's give ourselves another 10 seconds
to complete the voting
i think we have now 80 percent of the
audience that's what they thank you
thanks very much for your participation
this is really great um and let me
share the result with you um so
according to to to the group present on
the call today
nearly 50 believe that productivity
has increased 34 percent say the
productivity remained the same
and for 17 of you it actually went
down well
let me say that once again uh
this is really a great audience because
you are
exactly matching uh what we see
uh in our survey that that's um that's
really impressive
um if you look at the slide um
concerning productivity our respondents
say at 47
versus 48 in our survey today that it
has
increased for 38
it has stayed the same and you said 34
this is unbelievable and only 14 see a
reduction
in our survey which is exactly the same
thing
that this audience is actually
considering
and to be to be fair with you it goes
really against the sentiment that most
people manager
were having before the pandemic
now in our survey the middle east
northern africa
region has shown some differences
with the rest of the sample a
significant proportion
felt that the productivity decreased
this might be a point we could discuss
during the discussion later with holut
it seemed that
the connectivity challenges faced in
that region
might partly explain these results
overall our results are aligned with
other reports published on the subject
for instance std by stanford university
of 16 000 workers over nine months
found that working from home increased
productivity by 13 percent
and i guess that we all experience the
multiple reasons which can explain
a higher productivity level when working
from home
the absence of commuting time is a major
one
the absence of distractions since we
have no calling
colleagues popping up in our office
maybe also the difficulty to separate
work time from personal time
leading to more hours in front of our
computer
maybe also the fact that our boss um
think that we are supposed to be
constantly reachable and and keep on
sending uh information and requests many
elements
explain this strain
what we have reported here and i guess
um
what you used to base your answer to to
a poll
is much more diffic is a question of
perception and it's much more difficult
to evaluate properly productivity with
precise metrics
so this is what motivated the question
we are referring to in this next slide
using a variety of tools and tactics can
be helpful
in keeping productivity levels up and
maintain competitive advantage
so we asked our audience how
productivity was measured
while they were working from home and we
listed a certain number of tools
that you can see on on the slide the
results are a bit difficult to interpret
there is no
one leading reporting method and
multiple systems are used
interestingly however approaches using
task
or time tracking and productivity
tracing tools
seem to be used in similar proportion
compared to the more traditional methods
and if we zoom on north america the data
are not shown on this slide but they
have been captured by the survey
so on north america 45 percent of
respondents indicated that
employee productivity has increased now
over the forty five percent of these
forty five percent twenty two percent
are measured through milestone trade
through milestone tracing
twenty eight percent are measured
through monthly or quarterly reporting
22 percent use time and or
task tracing and 22 percent
use objectives or key result system
i would say it will be interesting
and maybe a bit frightening to observe
how management methods
evolve after the pandemic
indeed working remotely beca if working
remotely becomes the norm it
really contributes to increasing the
percentage of a working time spent via
digital devices
less physical meeting more online
interaction
as a consequence the vast majority of
work time
can be tracked and analyzed i guess this
consideration goes beyond the scope of
this survey
and is more a personal reflection but it
there might be some consequences with
um the vast majority of the working time
of employee
being technically trackable
i have one last slide and and this one
concludes
my section before i hand over to wanita
i just want to inform you that
we have produced a whitepaper which
details most of the points
i address in this presentation it will
be
available or it is already available
from the respective websites of the
different organization
presenting today the second part
of the webinar will enable us to share
more regional
flavor uh and views about these topics
and of course address questions coming
from the audience
so with this back to you ranita and
thank you for for your attention
thank you very much vincent that's um
really interesting um and i think a lot
of food for thought
as vincent mentioned there is the all
the findings is available in a white
paper
which the respective regions will
distribute to their
member database so just in conclusion
we're going to
enter into our round table discussion
now but
just a quick recap on some of the
recommendations
that i think you know is important
so i think what's really
you know been highlighted by the
research that we
have discovered is that it takes a few
initiatives with priority to set a
policy
to revisit delivery metrics and to
educate employees
on online tools that can be used to
capture this work from home
opportunity we know that the pandemic
caught everybody off guard employees
were literally
overnight told to go home and to start
work from home and many of them weren't
prepared
to make things worse many employees
were in a hard lockdown where schools
were closed where suddenly they were
being mom
dad as well as a caregiver
online homeschooler and
they had to remain productive within
their environment
we believe and understand that that must
have had a massive impact on their
productivity as they were trying to
juggle
children and feeding and education
together with their with their
day-to-day jobs
but that's quite unusual what's more
important for us is to understand
what this looks like going forward in a
normal work from home environment with
schools that are open
and with adequate support for people
working from home
the other thing that was highlighted is
that when possible
we need to and companies need to
consider offering a subsidy to employees
to encourage them to follow the company
vision to work from home
many people don't have adequate
resources
to provision their own environment and
here a subsidy of sorts
or an incentive of sorts would really
make a big difference and then to use a
combination of tools to measure
productivity at both
a business unit and a company wide level
so really what we what we believe is
that companies need to revisit
how productivity is measured and this is
one of the things that came from
people is to say that the old-fashioned
ways of
measuring kpis is not going to
necessarily
um work going forward and that these
need
to be um need to be revisited
revisit it and then the procurement and
production forecasted
should no longer be three years out i
think we've all learned that our lives
can be upset
in a in a moment's time um as
as we see in south africa currently for
those
of you who are following um the news um
and then we need to advocate for fiber
to the home to support work from home
you know we are very faithful believers
that's the work
that work from home will produce many
significant
benefits for society
vincent sort of touched on it in south
africa
it's called semigration of people that
are not moving beyond the borders of the
country
but they are certainly moving around
we've seen
massive semigration of people
moving from johannesburg pretoria to
coastline trying to find a better
quality of life
we believe that work from home is good
for the environment
we believe that it will curb
urbanization our cities are bursting out
of their seams
and we believe that if we can find and
encourage people to work from home
that it will be very good for
organization the other thing is of
course there's this massive
impact on the quality of life for people
working in smaller communities
and in addition to that we've seen that
many of our small towns and our rural
communities
need to be rejuvenated a lot of them are
at risk of becoming ghosts down
their infrastructure is falling apart
and if we can
encourage work from home and allow
people to work from anywhere which is
after all our message
then you know we will also see a
rejuvenation
of small towns so at this point we're
going to move into our
our q a um with our round
table participants which is the
leadership of the global fiber
council alliance and it gives me great
pleasure now to
also introduce gary bolton the president
and ceo of the fiber broadband
association
based in north america and gary i think
it's really
really really early morning for you so
um
we hope um you know that you are that
you're well and thank you so much for
joining us
uh we know it's difficult to accommodate
all the all the time zones
um it's also my privilege to bring uh
hulu aldorgam
in um i think you're based in dubai if
i'm not mistaken
um thank you very much for joining us
today although the time difference is
not
as bad you know it's a little bit better
and then rusafe from ftth council asia
pacific welcome russafi
um it'll be nice if each one can just
tell us where you're based
um and then sort of what time it is
there with you
and whether we're having a juice or a
strong cup of
java to stay awake or prepare a warm cup
of milk before we go to bed
um and gary i think i'm going to start
with hugh
um while we give vincent a moment to
have a
just a comfort break um so
latam um obviously is part of your
region and and i'm curious to understand
um a little bit um whether they were
significant differences
between what you experienced in north
america versus what the the latam region
experienced thanks juanita
and as you said you can see it's a
little bit dark in my background it's um
i guess it's uh 3 45 a.m
here so it's a little bit early i'm in
um i'm
in my home in huntsville alabama so uh
if you know where that is
on the map uh but yeah so the you know
i'm responsible for the western
hemisphere so the
fiber broadband association north
america and
our latam chapters and so what was kind
of interesting is there was a
pretty wide range of connectivity
challenges
and i think if you look remember that
chart that showed the different
technologies that we used
um across the um across the globe it
varied quite a bit you know where you
know you look at
the middle east north africa was much
more wireless
you know in the u.s we saw a little bit
of satellite
certainly our audience had a high usage
of fiber at home which was good
but we saw that especially in latin
america we saw
some interesting things in that it even
though it had the most used to fiber the
homeowner responses
we saw the highest level of lack of
internet connectivity so basically
if you weren't connected to fiber home
you were really suffering
and we also saw the
high levels of bandwidth constraints and
so we had in north america we had done a
study
during on the pandemic that looked at
rationing
and we saw that the lower your bandwidth
so if you
were a rural area and you had you know
like say four megabits downstream one
megabit upstream
you were um rationing you know spending
11 hours a week
basically sitting around waiting um for
internet to to work and you were telling
your kids to get off you know there
might be no in their school from home or
your spouse might be doing a zoom video
but
it made it very difficult for multiple
family members to be online at the same
time
due to rationing so you know i think one
of the
the fortunate things about the timing of
the pandemic
is that you know if you look at like 10
years ago a decade ago
our national broadband plan in north
america was at one megabit so i think we
would have all been
struggling a lot so you know
bandwidth connectivity is definitely
showed up as being paramount during the
pandemic
thanks thanks for that gary i think um
you know we've seen that
that's something certainly that i think
uh you we've seen across
the world and um we're forced
forecasting that you know demand to
absolutely increase i think globally
um putting a lot of pressure on
operators
i wanted to ask you something next you
know
there's an old saying i actually wrote
it down because i didn't want to get it
wrong
there's an old saying that goes managers
think they witness productivity
when in fact they only witness presence
and you know covet 19 proved to many
companies that
not all employees need to be present in
the office to remain productive
and companies are seeing this immense
opportunity to reduce their overheads
you know by reducing the amount of
facilities that they have in physical
workspace
um you know that they have to um
that that that they have to be paying
for monthly and certainly we've seen in
south africa
one of our largest banks is a bank
called netbank it's what we call one of
the big five
um and they announced a week ago that
they will have a permanent work from
home strategy now
going forward so
i i we expect that this will give rise
then to the
semigration that we refer to of people
moving to
the zoom towns as it's called in in the
us
but i guess my question is whether you
think this would then trigger companies
to try to
renegotiate employee benefits you know
we all talk about
quality of life in small towns and you
know
you know the lower cost of living etc
but
do you think that um because it's less
expensive to live in remote areas that
companies will
opportunistically try to say well now we
need to renegotiate your package you
know one of our findings is that
um recommendations is that people are
saying
um you know they want an incentive yet
conversely we're seeing that
that come companies are potentially
looking
towards renegotiating do you think that
this is going to be a trend
well thank you for listening and thank
you everybody and thank you all that can
be
joining us today and you know from
different time zones
and um uh allowing me first
say that i think there are so many
companies in our region
so it's not uh or i can say it's
uncharted
territory in terms of what
policy and work from home experience
especially for the local companies
because as you know we have
international companies and local
companies
um i would like to say that yes we have
seen
in the region some companies who are
reducing their uh
interviews to have uh or communicate
uh to a different country with uh less
expensive in front of
uh accommodation uh versus uh reduction
so i think yeah in the long run it's
working from home
and nobody will know how long it will
stay or it can become like a new
future uh i think yes there are so many
companies
let's say countries to different
countries but
i believe that your companies should
work more on the real time
which legal framework that all the
employees
are more organized and deal with or the
impact of those things
i would like to uh if you allow me to
comment on one of the known figures in
this study within the productivity
as we saw in the study that
mainly most of the reasons that were
activating our
almost um four to three percent of the
respondents
from the lunar country said that the
productivity decreased
i would say that you know they have been
through exposing um
let's during the project money forward
and come from natural
resources like all india and the jewish
public challenges even prior to the
pandemic
all the challenges go up into visa and
the pandemic human resources
we've done into the surgery results so
that um
this result it was a combination of many
elements
occurred at the same time uh first uh we
can say the law works from home policy
priorities
uh which means that this option was not
um
listed before uh probably 19 and it
needs uh time to be adapted
by the employees and the country and one
more reason also i would like to say
that
i'm sorry to interrupt the the line is
is actually quite bad
so we we have me we have many uh
attendees um sending messages in in that
direction i'm really sorry
could you maybe con conclude rapidly
because the
their struggle to to hear you and i
don't want to
give them a bad experience all right can
you hear me well now
it's still problematic it's probably the
line or
or the microphone um you
have a headset or something then we can
come back to you
all right okay
thanks um on that note you know you come
from a region and you represent a region
in asia pacific that's
that's really varied i mean you've got
um
you've got countries that have just got
like absolutely
um the connectivity that that that we
can only dream of and then you've got
that countries that um you know really
struggle with getting
um connectivity um you know rolled out
um so so just in general
how has how has the the pandemic
influenced
um the rollout in your region and has it
had an
impact you know more particularly on the
countries that are lagging
in the deployment of broadband
infrastructure
uh thank you waiter am i audible
yes you are thank you
thank you uh for the opportunity
uh so uh i'm rusaffi alam
uh from asia pacific i bought to the
home council asia pacific i'm the
general manager so uh
the question to answer your question
juanita
as you mentioned that we in apac cover
the highest fiber deployed market
in the world such as japan south korea
and china as well as some
developing nations also we have who
are in recent time excelling in the
recent years
in terms of fiber deployment namely uh
philippines
india vietnam thailand malaysia
indonesia they all are in the forefront
of
uh year-on-year growth around uh
between 20 to 40 growth rate and
india uh being the topper for its
fantastic
growth rate of uh 230 percent
than the previous years which is right
really uh amazing
uh to no note uh so i i just want to
give example about
how the deployment and the growth is uh
going ahead uh again just
giving you an example about india and
philippines specifically
uh where the average broadband speed
uh were 32 mbps in india in mid
2020 now the average speed is
uh 52 megabits per second so
which is like a very uh high
kind of uh jump this whole country is on
fire
and uh their mnos and fixed operators
are doing really great
uh also uh talking about philippines
uh it has jumped about 35 points from
21 to 57 mbps
in just one year uh so this clearly
shows
uh the infrastructure is improving
heavily
and the capacity is steadily going up so
i can conclude that improvements of five
years
uh has already done in 2020 to 2021 time
frame
due to the pandemic prices by these the
telcos and the service provider
as as well as the customer are more
focused on
quality internet which is taking shape
uh by fiverr deployment in our region
and it will go even higher uh in the
coming days
which will eventually give a push for
5g smart cities and iot development
which we
aim for the next generation so
thank you uh that that was my part
uh russell if i'm not mistaken i think
you based in bangladesh
uh yes exactly i'm based in bangladesh
my time is
like 3 p.m afternoon
good thank you thank you very much um
vincent i'm going to
ask you a very similar question i want
to know
you know we always look at developed
countries like first world countries and
you know we
we sort of hang on the lips of the fcc
and the european commission about their
you know their broadband strategies and
you know and and
we know that they've got visions has the
pandemic accelerated
those visions um have the european
commission made
any new announcements or are they
sticking to their guns and saying this
is our 2050 or you know whatever vision
um and um or are they are they finding
ways of accelerating broadband
especially to to more rural areas
i think the pandemic has essentially
accelerated things
uh that's true of the vision
and and plan of the european commission
this is also true of the action
of the different member states
it really helped politicians
give priority to infrastructure
development
and has really contributed to very
concrete
acceleration of their plan question is
no longer whether or not
fiber is what is required the question
is how fast and how
deep can fiber can be deployed so
we moved from a question of
choice in favor or not of fiber to a
question of how do we implement it
and the the commission is also producing
uh recommendation and directive and
toolboxes
uh best practices to to help uh really
um from an operational standpoint uh
support the activity of the different
member state the other thing i would
just briefly highlight is the fact it
was striking
that um ftth deployment and telecom in
general is now
seen in combination with the
the fight against climate change uh
politicians are seeing
a digital society as one side of
uh the same coin as a sustainability
work
and they see fth deployment as an
essential
enabler of digital society which will
help us
organize the society
organize the society uh to be
sustainable
sorry about that i thought i was on me
somebody tried to put some water down
for me um so then
i think we're pretty much out of time
i want to um thank everybody
for their time today um and um
and you know it's really been a a
phenomenal privilege to work with
this leadership all of whom you have met
this morning
there's another session that will taking
place my afternoon
gary it'll be a more respectable hour
for you
so we will we look forward to seeing you
everybody a little bit later for the
north america
chapter session thank you everybody for
your
time um we're going to catch up with you
this afternoon session
um you know very interesting remarks i
know we spoke
um before the sessions you know in our
in our prep sessions and you've got a
really interesting
um you know take on things that that's
different so we look forward to
um hearing from you and russell we know
that it'll be
quite late for you when you join us
again but thank you everybody for your
time
um and of course be reminded that the
information will be shared it's
available
on most websites and or will be shared
amongst the members
but thank you one everyone and have a
great day and
we look forward to keeping in contact
take care
thank you bye-bye